salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
dans quelques jours sort Napoléon le
dernier film de rid Lescott du coup avec
thbao de la chaîne Histoire appliquée on
a décidé de faire une petite battle
autour d'anecdote portant sur la vie de
l'empereur j'ai un peu fouillé et j'ai
appris des choses très étonnantes le
gagnant ne repartira pas les mains vides
le perdant lui offre une place pour
aller voir le film et accroche-toi Jamie
napoléon n'a presque aucun secret pour
moi c'est ce qu'on verra
première question thbao tu sais
évidemment que le tombeau de Napoléon se
trouve aux Invalides à Paris mais as-tu
déjà entendu parler de cette rumeur
selon laquelle ce n'est pas la dépouille
de Napoléon qui se trouverait à
l'intérieur j'espère que tu plaisantes
Jamy bien sûr que je la connais ton
histoire je connais même le nom de
l'homme qui a lancé la rumeur en tout
cas il l'a popularisé c'est George Retif
de la Bretonne un journaliste français
passionné d'histoire en 1969 il écrit un
livre intitulé anglais rendez-nous
Napoléon dans lequel il affirme que
c'est le corps d'un autre homme qui se
trouverait aux Invalides bravo thbao ce
livre a fait l'effet d'une bombe au
moment de sa sortie l'auteur affirme que
peu de temps après la mort de Napoléon
survenu le 5 mai 1821 les Anglais
auraient exhumé son corps de sa tombe et
l'auraient remplacé par les restes de
son maître d'hôtel Cipriani décédé lui
aussi à Saint-Hélène mais 3 ans plusôt
c'est donc la dépouille de Cyprian et
non celle de Napoléon qui aurait été
rapatrié à Paris le 15 décembre 1840
exactement et pour justifier sa thèse
Retif de la Bretonne s'appuie sur
différents éléments mentionnés sur le
rapport
d'exhumation les dents du mort sont très
blanches alors que celles de Napoléon
avait la réputation d'être très mauvaise
et puis il y a aussi ces deux vases qui
contiennent le cœur et l'estomac de
l'empereur ils sont censés avoir été
déposés au coin du cercueil or
bizarrement on les retrouve entre les
jambes de la dépouilles est-ce que tu
sais pourquoi les Anglais auraient
orchestré cette machination non mais
vas-y je t'écoute à l'époque il
craignait que les Français ne procèd à
des analyses toxicologiques dans le but
de prouver que Napoléon a été empoisonné
pour éviter le scandale ils auraient
donc transféré les véritables cendres de
l'empereur dans un endroit plutôt
incongru tu sais où à l'abbaye de
Westminster Napoléon aurait été enterré
sous une dalle anonyme cette histoire a
fait beaucoup de bruit en 1969 au moment
de la sortie du livre pu on l'a oublié
jusqu'en 2002 où pour être fixé une
bonne fois pour toutes un historien
nommé Bruno roi Henri propose que l'on
fasse un prélèvement ADN sur la
dépouille qui se trouve dans le cercueil
des Invalides afin de le comparer avec
l'ADN des descendants de la famille
bonapar c'est ça la demande est faite
auprès de l'État français la réponse du
ministère de la Défense tombe elle est
sans appel c'est miett d'ailleurs sachez
qu'aucun historien digne de ce nom ne
valide cette hypothèse farfelue le corps
de Napoléon aé été authentifié devant
plusieurs témoins dignes de fois juste
avant son transfert en France donc
jusqu'à preuve du contraire absolument
rien ne permet de dire que ce n'est pas
son corps qui se trouve aux
Invalides tiens jamis une question que
tout le monde se pose est-ce que tu sais
pourquoi sur de nombreuses
représentations de l'époque Napoléon a
la main sur l'estomac on lit souvent
qu'il adoptait cette posture en raison
de douleur qu'il aurait eu à l'estomac
et bien pas du tout en fait il s'agit
tout simplement d'une façon de se tenir
en respectant les bonnes manières dans
la haute société de l'époque il était
très mal vu de se tenir les bras
ballants ou même les bras croisés et
bien sûr pas question de mettre les
mains dans les poches hein il doit tenir
son rang c'est un militaire il monte à
cheval et lui le petit Corse d'origine
modeste il doit pouvoir montrer qu'il
est aussi bien élevé que tous les grands
d'urope qui attendent la moindre
occasion pour se moquer de lui
d'ailleurs Napoléon n'est pas le seul à
se tenir ainsi la main dans le gilet on
retrouve cette posture sur de nombreux
tableaux représentant des hommes
importants au début du 19e siècle
finalement il ne faisait que suivre la
mode de son temps on continue avec les
idées reçues sur Napoléon on a beaucoup
parlé de sa taille mais à ton avis thbao
combien mesure est-il alors de mémoire
c'est pas très grand quelque chose comme
1,65 il me semble perdu d'après son
médecin François antomark il mesurait 5
pieds 5 pouces ce qui correspond à un
peu moins d'un,60 8 oh franchement il
abuse là à 3 cm près je suis désolé
j'étais pas loin dans tous les cas
Napoléon n'était pas très grand ah les
chiffres sont les chiffres tu mesures
combien thbao 1,89 évidemment c'est
grand et d'une manière générale
aujourd'hui on estime qu' 1,68 pour un
homme c'est plutôt petit dans une
manifestation ou dans une rame de métro
on aurait du mal à repérer Napoléon mais
si l'on compare à la taille moyenne des
hommes au début du 19e siècle qui était
d'environ 1 m 64 on peut dire qu'il
était plutôt grand pour l'époque mais
alors d'où lui vient cette réputation et
bien des Anglais les peintres et les
caricaturistes le représentaient
exagérément petit une façon de se moquer
de lui tu marques un point Jamie mais en
fait ce n'est pas la seule explication
Napoléon s'entourait d'hommes de très
grande taille pour composer sa garde
d'élite ils étaient affublés de grands
couvrechefs et de plumet qui les rendait
encore plus grand alors forcément à leur
côté il apparaissait plus petit que dans
la réalité et puis à cela il faut
ajouter qu'il traîne comme un boulet ce
surnom de Petit Caporal que lui avait
donné ses soldats après la victoire de
Lodi contre les Autrichiens en 1796 ce
grade totalement fictif tendait surtout
à souligner son courage et non sa taille
mais ça a créé beaucoup de confusion
dans les
esprits tu l'as dit Jamie Napoléon a
souvent été l'objet de moquerie par
exemple savais-tu qu'en 1779 lorsqu'il
intègre le collège d'tin en sonéloir on
se moque de lui tant son axent cor est
prononcé et je peux même te dire que ses
camarades de classe le surnommaient la
paayonné en référence à son prénom que
Napoléon lui-même prononçait napooné à
cette époque il maîtrise si mal le
français qu'il doit suivre des cours
pour s'améliorer ça peut surprendre mais
ça s'explique lorsque Napoléon arrive au
monde le 15 août 1769 la Corse n'est
française que depuis 1 an on y parle
deux langues proches de l'italien le
Corse et le génois donc en langue corse
qu'il pronce c'est premier mot et qu'il
communique avec les membres de sa
famille pendant toute son enfance
d'ailleurs Napoléon conservera toute sa
vie son accent il en gardera aussi de
nombreuses lacunes en orthographe et
pour éviter de faire trop de fautes dans
ses courriers et bien on sait qu'il les
dictait à des secrétaire particulier qui
eux étaiit bon en grandemère et en
orthographe mais ça ne l'empêchera pas
de laisser derrière lui un héritage
considérable je pense que vous allez
être surpris par les nombreuses
institutions qu'il a fondé qui sont
aujourd'hui encore en place est-ce que
ça te dit quelque chose Tibo et
là-dessus il ne m'aura pas non plus
commençons par parler du bac par exemple
c'est une invention de Napoléon qui l'a
créé en 1808 pour préparer le bac bien
sûr il faut aller au lycée et ça c'est
lui aussi créé par la loi du 1er mai
1802 d'ailleurs vous voyez cette
personne en uniforme il s'agit d'un
préfet il est chargé de l'administration
dans les départements bien sans
Bonaparte cet homme exercerait sans
doute une autre fonction c'est en effet
lui qui a créé le corps préfectoral le
17 février 1800 enfin bon thba a quand
même oublié le plus important ce livre
le Code civil publié le 21 mars 1804 il
regroupe l'ensemble des lois qui
régissent nos droits et nos obligations
le mariage le divorce la propriété ou
encore l'héritage alors bien sûr il a
évolué avec le temps mais près de la
moitié de ces
2280 article date de l'époque
napoléonienne enfin peut-être plus
surprenant encore Napoléon a aussi créé
la Banque de France la Légion d'honneur
le ramassage des ordures et la
numérotation des rues instauré pour
faciliter la collecte de l'impôt destiné
à financer ses guerres et les platanes
il a oublié les platanes tous ces arbres
sur le bord de nos route c'est Napoléon
qui les a fait planter et vous savez
pourquoi pour que ces armées puissent
marcher à
l'ombre puisque tu as l'air de tout
connaître sur Napoléon saurais-tu me
dire combien il a eu d'enfants enfin
jamis évidemment que je sa il a eu un
fils Napoléon François Joseph Charles
Bonaparte plus connu sous le nom de
Napoléon 2 on l'appelait aussi l'iglon
il a été titré roi de Rome à sa
naissance en 1811 mais il n'aarigné que
15 jours et le pauvre garçon est mort
prématurément de la tuberculose à l'âge
de 21 ans en 1832 il en a oublié quatre
Napoléon a eu cinq enfants un fils
légitime dont Tibo vient de nous parler
et quatre autres enfants illégitimes
ceux cette fois c'est moi qui marque un
non quatre points ah mais je le savais
ça en plus son premier fils se nommait
Charles Léon il est né en 1806 de ses
amours avec Éléonore de Nuel de la
plaigne une suivante de sa sœur Caroline
plus porté au plaisir qu'on travaille ce
monsieur meurt en 1880 sans argent et
dit-on avec de lourdes dettes de jeu la
même année l'empereur a eu une aventure
avec une certaine Françoise Marie Émilie
le roi qui donne naissance à une fille
Émilie pellapra qui deviendra princesse
de Brigode par le mariage enfin en 1810
Napoléon aura deux autres fils Eugène
mger de mulfeld né de sa relation avec
une aristocrate autrichienne dont je
vous passe le nom de famille comme son
papa Eugène mégerle deviendra homme
politique mais en Autriche enfin
Alexandre comte de balevski fils de
Marie valevska une aristocrate polonaise
ce dernier a fait une brillante carrière
de sénateur et de ministr en France sous
le règne de son cousin Napoléon I
regardez bien il y a un petit TER de
famille pour finir en beauté jamis
petite devinette est-ce que tu as déjà
entendu parler de Charles Joseph
Bonaparte je paris qu'il ne sait
pas dans mon souvenir c'est un neveu de
Napoléon mais un neveu américain je me
trompe c'est presque ça il s'agit plus
exactement de son petit neveu il est né
à Baltimore d'une mère américaine et a
fait une brillante carrière politique au
sein du parti républicain en 1905 il est
même nommé procureur général des
États-Unis c'est l'équivalent de
ministre de la justice en France mais ce
n'est pas le plus important Charles
Joseph Bonaparte est aussi à l'origine
d'un organisme que tout le monde connaît
tu vois de quoi je parle jamis tu ne
m'auras pas thbao c'est lui qui a eu
l'idée de créer aux États-Unis le Bureau
of Investigation le Boi un organisme
chargé de lutter contre le crime
organisé l'ancêtre on a deviné du FBI
évidemment je m'incline je suis très
mauvais en calcul mais je pense que
c'est quand même toi qui a gagné du coup
c'est moi qui t'invite la semaine
prochaine à découvrir le nouveau film de
rid Lescott merci pour cette battle en
tout cas quant à vous je vous remercie
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout j'espère qu'elle vous a donné envie
d'en apprendre encore plus sur Napoléon
et puis si ce format vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un message pour
nous dire à très bientôt passer une
excellente semaine chers épicurieuses et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
épicurieux